Trascrizione: Cinzia Acciarri
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
È lo spirito della gente,
che riesce ad uscire di casa
per mettersi a contatto con gli altri.
Qui non succede per niente,
vede, non si sente neanche [nessuno].
La signora che avete visto nel filmato
si chiama Franca.
Noi l'abbiamo conosciuta
- lei vive a Trieste -
perché un giorno,
passando davanti
al "frutta e verdura" Masood
nella strada dove abito,
mi ha chiamato, Masood,
e mi ha detto:
- Guarda, c'è una lettera per te.
Questa è la lettera,
l'originale della lettera.
È una calligrafia molto bella,
una calligrafia antica, molto chiara.
Normalmente noi riceviamo
queste lettere
con richieste di supporti economici:
questo caso era completamente diverso.
Io l'ho letta con molta attenzione,
e qui c'è la storia.
La signora disse - Io ho 81 anni,
ho vissuto a Bologna tanti anni,
mi sono poi trasferita anni fa a Trieste,
e in questa città io non mi trovo più,
non so cosa fare.
Ho letto dell'esperienza
di 'Social Street'
su un giornale, l'intervista
che le han fatto
ho letto del frutta e verdura
- che è il nostro fermoposta -
e mi ha mandato questa lettera:
faccio questa richiesta a 'Social Street',
aiutatemi a tornare a Bologna,
non fatemi morire in una città
dove la gente non si saluta.
E la cosa è strana, molto originale,
perché a 300 km di distanza,
e a 45 anni, anche, di distanza
Federico Bastiani aveva avuto
lo stesso problema, la stessa intuizione
che, pur vivendo in una città
come Bologna da diversi anni,
passando per Via Fondazza
non conosceva assolutamente nessuno.
Noi ce l'abbiamo questa sensazione,
molto spesso, però ci fermiamo lì.
Mentre Federico,
gruppo dei dreamer, ha detto:
Va beh, proviamo a fare qualcosa,
vediamo se utilizzando un mezzo
che normalmente viene utilizzato
per mettere in contatto
le persone che vivono lontano
posso conoscere il mio vicino di casa.
Follia? Lui l'ha fatto, comunque.
Questo è l'originale del primo volantino
che lui ha creato e ha attaccato
sotto i portici di Bologna,
sotto gli archi dei portici
di Via Fondazza
per informare cittadini e residenti
che c'era questo gruppo.
Questo è un volantino importante
perché dice esattamente qual era
lo scopo di questo gruppo.
L'obiettivo è quello di creare
un punto di riferimento
per i residenti di questa storica strada
- c'è ancora l'errore originale - al fine
di socializzare, organizzare incontri
esprimere necessità, o esigenze:
una sorta di 'bacheca stradale'.
Settembre 2013: ci si aspettava
- io sono stato uno
dei primi che ha aderito,
ci aspettavamo pochissime adesioni,
10-20-30 persone che aderissero.
È stata una follia totale,
perché in poco tempo
veramente centinaia di persone
si sono iscritte a questo gruppo.
Non ce l'aspettavamo assolutamente,
e abbiamo cominciato
a farci delle domande:
perché, cosa succede,
perché queste persone hanno
- cos'è questa corsa
ad aderire a questo gruppo?
La risposta la lasciamo in sospeso,
penso di avere il tempo
di parlarne poi dopo.
Quello che è interessante
è quello che è successo:
Un gruppo Facebook
è un mondo molto virtuale,
stiamo nel virtuale.
Cosa c'entra con la strada, Facebook?
Può non c'entrar niente,
però Facebook
è uno strumento come tanti altri,
come il martello che si utilizza per
i chiodi o per rompersi un dito.
Quello che è successo, immediatamente,
è che le persone hanno cominciato
a interagire sul web
e a scambiarsi informazioni.
Quindi tutto quello che succedeva
restava sul web,
quindi queste persone
che non si conoscevano
hanno cominciato a conoscersi.
In che modo?
Semplicemente chiedendo
informazioni sulla strada.
Uno dei punti forti di questa struttura è:
'Residenti in Via Fondazza a Bologna',
un posto molto delimitato,
quindi le persone a cui chiedevi,
dov'è il medico migliore?
ti rispondevano immediatamente,
per ogni domanda tre risposte.
Dov'è il posto che ... chi sa
gli orari del calzolaio ...
Chi mi può dire dov'è il miglior negozio
di frutta e verdura e via dicendo.
Quindi le persone hanno cominciato
a interagire fra di loro
a un livello assolutamente virtuale.
Sulla strada non c'eravamo ancora.
Però, automaticamente,
le persone hanno cominciato
anche a fidarsi degli altri e a dire:
"Bene, chi mi può dare una mano?
Ho la macchina ferma in strada,
chi mi può dare una mano a caricare,
cioè a riaccenderla e a spingerla".
Molto spesso la gente diceva,
vieni giù che siamo già qui
che ti diamo una mano
a spinger la macchina.
-Chi mi dà una mano,
per esempio, nel trasloco.
- Chi mi può, per esempio tenere
il gatto per una settimana, o un giorno.
Delle richieste di aiuto,
ma anche delle offerte,
"Ho un tavolo
che non mi serve più, chi lo vuole?"
Oppure: "vado in vacanza,
ho il frigorifero pieno.
A chi serve questo cibo, chi lo vuole?"
A questo punto, le persone
per forza di cose
si son dovute incontrare in strada,
e questi scambi sono aumentati,
in questo anno,
in maniera esponenziale.
Certamente, c'è da dire che,
a fronte di centinaia di persone
che si scrivevano e poi interagivano
la percentuale poi di persone
che si conoscevano veramente
era molto bassa.
Ma anche di questo penso
che parleremo in seguito.
La cosa importante
è che a un certo punto,
a parte questa automaticità dei rapporti,
di richieste che venivano dalle persone,
abbiamo cominciato a pensare
anche di fare qualcosa
che potesse attirare le persone in strada,
a prescindere dalle singole necessità.
Quindi a parte gli aperitivi,
i compleanni e via dicendo,
avevamo pensato:
"Questa la facciamo vedere
perché è la prima attività
che noi abbiamo fatto, organizzato".
Pensavamo a un flash mob di Natale:
c'erano due tre persone, in strada,
che sapevano suonare
quindi diciamo: "Proviamo a vedere
chi viene a festeggiare in strada
il 'Natale con noi'".
Bene, la sorpresa è stata
che in questa occasione
noi ci siamo trovati
con circa 200 persone in strada
e altre 200 alle finestre.
Erano praticamente due mesi
che era nato il gruppo,
quindi avevmo già avuto la sensazione
che qualcosa funzionava,
che le persone avevamo bisogno
di questa partecipazione.
Era una richiesta che facevano
di essere anche spinte a uscire
in strada e a partecipare.
Noi non abbiamo una sede prescelta,
non è un comitato,
non è un'associazione,
non ci sono tessere,
assolutamente niente.
La strada è il nostro luogo di ritrovo.
E quindi siamo andati avanti
anche con altre attività.
Un'altra molto bella, per esempio,
è stata uno shooting fotografico.
Un ragazzo che abita lì, nella strada,
lavora come manager
alla Laika di Firenze
e si è offerto di fotografare
tutti gli abitanti della strada.
Ha detto: "Vabbe',
verranno in cinque, sei".
150 persone, 200 persone
si sono presentate,
abbiamo fatto questa mostra
incredibile dei volti.
Però c'è da dire questo
- 'I Volti di Via Fondazza'.
Messa sul muro, vedete,
con le mollette, niente di che.
È un formato - sono fotocopie,
veramente, la qualità
non era così importante.
Per noi la cosa molto importante
è sempre quella:
creare delle attività per fare
in modo che le persone
abbiano una scusa per incontrarsi.
E andiamo avanti,
siam passati anche a letture
ad alta voce nei vari cortili,
quindi non andiamo in un posto specifico
ma nei diversi cortili delle case
a fare delle letture.
E di qua siamo passati a un altro livello.
L'altro livello è dire:
la strada di solito ha una storia,
e le storie bisogna conoscerle,
perché storia è appartenenza,
storia è qualcosa
che ti fa vedere non i muri
ma quello che c'è dietro i muri,
quello che c'è stato.
Questo è uno degli esempi,
le streghe di Via Fondazza, famosissime
- poi le streghe, voglio dire,
come [in] tutte le strade povere
era una categoria femminile ben definita,
che per sopravvivere
faceva i filtri d'amore,
ma faceva anche tutt'altro.
E anche queste storie,
Storia della Grande Fondazza
- cioè, Fondazza è una strada
dove viveva anche il pittore Morandi,
non Gianni come ha detto qualcuno:
"Possiamo intervistare il Morandi?"
Ho detto: "Mah, è un po' difficile,
perché è un po' morto".
Però in questa strada c'era Morandi,
Giorgio Morandi, che era assolutamente
un asociale incredibile,
però frequentata anche dal Carducci.
Quindi tutte le persone
che hanno in qualche modo interagito
con questi personaggi,
sono venute a parlare o restare,
e questa non è gente
che sta su Facebook,
queste sono persone che non utilizzano
assolutamente Facebook.
Un giorno ci siamo trovati
per strada un cartello:
E noi che non usiamo Facebook,
come facciamo a partecipare?
È molto, molto bello.
Questa è un'altra attività
in cui siamo scesi,
un terzo tipo di attività
in cui ci prendiamo cura del territorio,
delle cose che ci sono
nel nostro territorio,
la nostra strada.
In questo caso è proprio
il giardino di Morandi,
mandato completamente in rovina.
E ci siamo occupati noi,
poi, di ripulirlo.
Ci occupiamo delle fioriere,
ma ogni volta le costruiamo noi,
ogni volta il motivo è per ritrovarsi
la domenica mattina
a fare qualcosa insieme.
Socializzare è la cosa più importante.
L'altro punto certamente
è [che] prendersi cura
di una strada vuol dire
anche trovare dei posti
dove poter socializzare.
Le nostre città sono poverissime
di posti dove socializzare.
Se uno si vuol sedere
deve andare in un bar,
se vuol bere dell'acqua
e lasciamo perdere altri servizi.
Noi in pochi mesi siamo riusciti
a pedonalizzare questa piazzetta,
che è assolutamente
al centro della nostra strada,
con una chiesa bellissima
e con una storia bellissima
delle suore canterine di Santa Cristina,
che è un posto meraviglioso,
dove abbiamo fatto dei concerti, anche,
concerti fatti anche da [non chiaro].
Ci è stata data proprio
per la valenza sociale.
Allora, questo l'ho messo semplicemente
non per chissà che cosa,
ma in effetti noi ci sentiamo
un laboratorio di strada.
Quello che sta succedendo
in Fondazza è qualcosa
di incredibile perché
nessuno se l'aspettava, innanzitutto,
proprio assolutamente nessuno.
Noi abbiamo attualmente
fra le 25 e le 30 tesi di laurea
di sociologia, di antropologia,
di psicologia,
sì anche lo IED,
la Sapienza e via dicendo.
Questo veramente colpisce molto.
Tutto questo perché in Via Fondazza,
nel gruppo residente in Via Fondazza
siamo circa mille persone,
ma dopo vedremo che la cosa
si è assolutamente espansa.
C'è da considerare
realmente tantissime cose:
perché persone
che non si conoscono neanche
cominciano a voler partecipare
a un progetto di socialità,
cos'è successo?
La ultraottantenne signora che chiede
alla sua dirimpettaia - ultranovantenne
che chiede alla sua dirimpettaia:
"Ma dì su, ma cos'è 'sta 'social street?"
E quella glielo spiega, le dice:
"Ma allora cos'è, quello
che facevamo noi una volta
50 anni fa".
Beh sì, si faceva 50 anni fa,
ma adesso non si faceva più,
non si fa più,
cioè di interagire con le persone,
di salutarsi,
di scambiarsi il saluto, di conoscersi.
Si vive nelle strade
senza avere nessuna concezione
di chi sta vicino.
In questo modo, è questo lo scopo.
La socializzazione
molto spesso è semplice,
basta salutare le persone per strada.
Io lo vedo: io ci mettevo 5 minuti
a fare Via Fondazza, l'anno scorso,
quest'anno ci metto due ore e mezza,
quindi quando prendo il treno
vado da un'altra parte,
perché se no non arrivo in stazione.
Questo per dire che conosco le facce,
conosco i nomi delle persone,
conosco le storie delle persone,
e questo è assolutamente importante
perché ci arricchisce notevolmente.
Oggi abbiamo sentito
una cosa meravigliosa,
nella medicina - per esempio,
vivere un ambiente altamente sociale,
dove ti senti bene
fa diminuire del 20%,
se non sbaglio, è uno studio
recentemente pubblicato,
le malattie cardiovascolari.
Da un punto di vista economico,
vivere in un ambiente
dove c'è questo scambio,
- che non è il fine di 'social street',
non è assolutamente quello il fine -
però si risparmia, calcolando
intorno ogni famiglia,
intorno ai 2000 euro,
quindi è importante anche
questo punto di vista.
Ci vien da chiedere perché è più facile
che ci son più persone che chiedono
che quelle che danno.
Questo è un punto importante
anche da un punto di vista psicologico.
Perché ormai non siamo
neanche più abituati
a chiedere l'aiuto degli altri.
Noi abbiamo un rapporto
di uno a tre, uno a quattro,
penso che sia molto importante
rivedere anche questo punto.
Vado avanti velocemente.
Abbiam fatto il primo compleanno
quest'anno
con i 1000 iscritti,
ma i numeri non contano,
contano le interazioni tra le persone.
Noi non facciamo mai
assemblee enormi,
non ci servono, sono piccoli gruppi
che si organizzano,
per cui trekking urbano,
le cene e queste cose qui:
sono tutti piccoli gruppi di persone
che posson parlare
fra di loro e conoscersi.
Vado molto velocemente avanti
perché voglio tornare a dirvi
innanzitutto [che] in Italia, ormai,
sono centinaia le
'social street' presenti,
decine stanno nascendo
in tutto il mondo
su questo modello di Via Fondazza
e noi siamo molto orgogliosi
perché Fondazza è il primo modello
al mondo di 'social street'.
Siamo anche in America Latina
e in Nuova Zelanda,
in Croazia, e via dicendo.
Per gli ultimissimi secondi,
voglio soltanto ritornare
alla signora Franca.
Noi abbiamo pubblicato
la sua storia sulla nostra pagina
e immediatamente, in due giorni,
abbiamo trovato
chi si occupava del trasloco gratis
da Trieste a Bologna,
le abbiamo trovato la casa a Bologna,
l'ho chiamata e le ho detto:
"Signora Franca è tutto a posto".
E lei mi fa: "Guardi signor Luigi,
veramente, a questo punto qui,
io ho paura di tornare a Bologna.
Il mio era uno sfogo,
mi sentivo veramente sola,
adesso so che ci siete,
quindi per il momento
voglio restare qui".
Questa è un'altra bella lezione
perché alla fine molto spesso
non abbiamo bisogno
di grandi aiuti
ma di sapere che,
nel caso in cui ne avremo bisogno,
qualcuno c'è.
(Applausi)